[Music]
Jane the Virgin's been a huge hit here
but now it's shown worldwide yeah and
I'm curious have you had this phenomenon
where like what's the farthest place
from America that where you've been
recognized and it freaked you out
Macau China in China they recognized
there's one person from Macau China in
this yeah yeah I was the show was only
like six weeks in but China and the
Philippines had already bought it and it
was already airing there and I went to
go see my father
referee his last championship fight
which was Pacquiao vs. Algeria back in
last year and we're walking up to the
venue and that's older gentleman from
Macau China was like you're Jane the
virgin and I was like did I and my
boyfriend at that time was like oh my
god and then I slapped him and then I
slapped the guy that recognized me do
you mean you high-fived em no I slept oh
wow raised it into the night let's be
weird with people yeah when they forget
your name they're like virgin that's a
weird thing
yeah he's so angry they're so angry
about it just true you once you once
dated for a while a guy an older guy who
was a virgin at a later stage in life is
that right yes yeah definitely did what
was what was his story um he was saving
himself from marriage and it was super
respectable and he was awesome and
lovely and I didn't know I was gonna be
doing character study that's this is
before yeah this is before you did your
show this was way before I did my face a
lot of self-control I have to say
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you just mentioned your dad your dad was
a big-time they wanted know if you could
break the virgin yeah no your dad when
you mentioned him when you mentioned the
your dad a big time boxing ref okay
yeah big time boxing and so did he teach
you to box he did he definitely did I
started boxing really really young me
and my two older sisters to defend her
did you want a box what as they know
anyone who knows me knows that my style
is the old yeah it's a lot of just
lifting the leg backing away I love it
it's why there were Irish prize fighters
in the 1880s but then never again nobody
you must be you must be pretty good okay
I mean yeah I'm okay yeah yeah I
wouldn't fight me that's interesting I
will not fight you
I refuse and I know that that's a big
relief for you you would clean my clock
so quickly I know nothing about it and
you do this and like hold me and then
I'd be like just do that
[Laughter]
the I don't think that would work
you would just punch up at my arm and
break it but have you like for example
you feel pretty good like if you were
walking down the street you're confident
that you know how to take care of
yourself yeah I don't really have like a
victim walk as kind of what they call it
in fighting and you know I I definitely
walk around pretty confidently mm-hmm
good for you I'm curious I'm curious if
you're dating a guy and he can't fight
at all is that a deal-breaker for you
would you would you want to be with a
guy who kind of knew how to take care of
himself I don't know if that would be a
deal-breaker for me what if he was a
physical coward I'm talking about myself
[Laughter]
[Applause]
like a guy who is like oh my god
you take care of this yeah I don't know
how well you would feel if I was like
baby get behind me you know it's okay
baby come on can you just yeah yeah not
cool yeah I mean it's I'm I have a
bigger bark than my bite really so you
can you can you can stop the fight
before you even start no you don't want
to do this trust me you don't want to do
this yeah my you don't want to do this
is so different from whether it's your
it I wouldn't your I don't want to do
this
you really no come on it's really sad